hi i'm eric boss and avengers end game's
biggest moment i think we can all agree
was cap picking up thor's hammer mjolnir
as much as some of us would have liked
thor double fisting it with stormbreaker
like a popsicle or a twix as guardian
hammers are best shared
and recently the directors russo
brothers and marvel head kevin feige
have revealed that
cap being worthy of wielding mjolnir is
actually something that has always been
the case
this is a pretty serious retcon that
makes us look back at
all of cap and thor's past moments
differently so here let's look back
and break it all down okay so in in-game
fat thor
steals his original hammer mjolnir from
asgard in 2013 that was the dark world
point in the timeline before mjolnir was
destroyed by hella in ragnarok that gave
thor two hammers
mjolnir and his newer weapon
stormbreaker later during the fight with
thanos thor gets
wrecked mjolnir tumbles over to the side
and cap
lifts it he uses it in a combination
with the shield to deliver a
beat down on the mad titan he uses all
the best moves twirling mjolnir to power
it up
summoning lightning he's like a freaking
natural with it thor sees this and
responds
i knew it because obviously this awesome
reveal was a call back to avengers age
of ultron during that test of strength
scene
where thor challenged each of the other
avengers to try to lift mjolnir and
prove their worth hawkeye banner stark
and brody together they all fail
but when cap gives it a try it budged
just a little
freaking thor out for a second until cap
threw up his hands stepped away and thor
took a big relieved swig of his beer
and when asked about this russo brothers
said that in their heads cap was
always able to wield mjolnir and that he
didn't know until that moment in ultron
when he tried to pick it up
because cap is humble and out of
deference to thor's ego
cap decided not to they said that every
marvel fan knew deep down in their heart
that cap was worthy and marvel head
kevin feige confirmed it
saying in a recent reddit amaa we think
he was always worthy and being polite an
age of ultron
yeah i'm working on my feige impression
so that makes it really fun to re-watch
the moment in age of ultron
cap must have seen the brief look of
panic on thor's face when the hammer
rocked
just slightly making that little squeak
and when you think about it it was
really smart of cap to hold back in this
moment because
thor like his friend from work the hulk
has a very fragile emotional equilibrium
like thor's power
is directly proportional to his
confidence and general mood like after
losing the thanos and infinity war and
then cutting off his head and end game
but still not bringing everyone back
thor
responded by carving out into melted ice
cream and moping about jane foster
the avengers need thor to think he's
invincible to have him at max
effectiveness
actually when you rewatch all of age of
ultron the opening minutes of that movie
established that cap has been getting
increasingly
familiar with mjolnir during that
opening battle against hydra there is
this one shot that
frames cap with a close-up of mjolnir
and this is right before a cap and thor
do their hammer plus shield combo move
they actually learn this after the first
avengers when they accidentally created
this same shockwave effect during their
first fight
and if you notice an in-game cap
actually replicates this move
on his own during his fight against
thanos he frisbees his shield at thanos
which thanos blocks but then cap throws
milner at the shield
creating this dong and a big shock wave
that knocks thanos to his feet
the worthiness to wield mjolnir comes
from a magical enchantment that
reads the one trying to lift it so
that's why you know tables and elevators
that
lifted aren't technically worthy this
whole idea of worthiness comes from
ancient mythology one notable example
being the legend of arthur and his sword
excalibur so it's not about strength
it's about
having the soul of a selfless hero to be
worthy to lift the weapon
and it's not that cap's recent heroics
in infinity war in an end game made him
suddenly worthy to pull this sword from
the stone he was always able to do it
arguably born able to do it that's why
he was chosen for the super soldier
experiment in the 40s dr erskine and
peggy carter saw that
even as a scrawny guy he possessed a
selflessness
and perseverance that when coupled with
physical strength would make him
unstoppable
really cap lifting mjolnir was a payoff
to the moment in the first avengers
movie
the argument between stark and cap when
cap accused tony of being
selfish and arrogant and tony accused
cap of just being a fortunate lab
experiment as opposed to being a hero
who
had to build himself the way tony did
everything special about you came out of
a bottle
endgame proved wrong both cap and stark
from that argument stark made the
sacrifice play in this movie and kat
proved that there was always a greater
worthiness to him than his super
strength and super agility
that was just stuff that did come out of
a bottle but the truly worthy soul
came from the fighter who could do this
all day i'm curious to know how all of
you guys reacted to this moment where
mjolnir was lifted so comment down below
with your best reaction
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at yavos subscribe to new rockstars and
subscribe to our inside marvel podcast
feed for early access to all of our
marvel coverage thank you for joining me
and um
when i needed my uber driver to lift my
heavy luggage into the trunk
uh yeah that was just me being like
happened acting polite to make him feel
better about his strength i was totally
worthy
[Music]
you